I'm freaked out over my brother
I freaked up oh because the shower are
you taking a shower what happened
what's this is what happened okay buddy
your flight was delayed thank God yeah
but we didn't know that at the time and
I woke up at I woke up at almost 3:00
and the flight was at like 420 no it was
but I thought it was fourth one that was
that four cars the airport and and I
wake up in my head I'm like it's 4:20 we
have to leave it's almost 3:00 and I
just woke up and I hear Steve taking a
shower in a row it rates me I'm
frantically
you know packing you know my teeth smell
bad
brushing my teeth I just woke up myself
okay so you're taking a long shower
though okay we get in the car we drive
no my mom came with us yeah my mom yeah
she because we had we rented a car and
then I was a hundred miles per hour on
the freeway my mom was gonna take care
of returning the car back yeah and we
get to the airport and as we were
pulling up I go we're not gonna make
it's 4:20 in and my brother goes it's
5:20 yeah he looked at it wrong I looked
at it wrong and plus it was delayed and
now by an hour yeah Wow which I knew but
I thought you guys would just be in the
airport on time anyways it didn't matter
yeah anyway I freaked we freaked out it
was a and we fought today okay so you
know brothers do you love me yeah I love
you man I do you don't wanna kill me
anymore no but there's certain things
that okay let's be there's certain
things that you do like once in a blue
moon yeah you cuz like you know he knows
me so well
he knows what exactly what button he'll
be like boom I just lose my mind he's
the only and he's the only person on
this earth that could do that to me
really yeah oh yeah I mean I have close
friends that know me know well they're
sir
friends that could do that too but they
don't yeah I mean so I yeah he gets in
these red zones yeah I mean I'm and and
usually they end up with me being
physically hurt I've attacked him there
is several where there's knockout Kings
is the night before your MADtv with the
knives with the knife yeah yeah and then
there's one where a FIFA mm that's why
it is like every couple years yeah
that's why I don't I refuse to play him
now he kind of eggs me like come on on
this plane I'm like no I'm not playing
yeah come on yeah but we got to the
ridge with it we get we can get to reg
without it what do you mean I can get
you there without oh yeah
well I'm saying these are specific
things that you do but to the to I just
wanted everyone listening right now
there was a moment where my brother and
I were about to physically in this
podcast no I was but just had week what
color are we started again yeah and we
Hugh he OMA but my brother grew because
I didn't I know and I'm giving you a
compliment okay my brother
usually when he's that mad will go to
poor violence no I don't know well you
did threaten me you see even come over
here but anyway arm he says gonna kiss
you yeah I you kill me but he he
refrained from getting violent and we
have to applaud his growth guys start
with but also I will say that I cited
with you Steve and I understood your
pain at the moment yeah as I do live
with your brother and I know that he
likes to push I'm a bad person
no you're not a bad person you're great
you just have a big-ass mouth
he's the kylo Ren yeah you don't know
where you if you're evil doesn't know so
since we're on this topic
yeah how do you personally cuz you guys
live together yeah I we were together
for three or four days and we were kind
of butting heads towards kind of yeah I
was getting on your nerves how do you
you with it no I look I thought you
could write memos of I'm gonna die look
there is something that people have know
about me I am quite possibly the most
patient person that I know I have the
patience of a [ __ ] my threshold for
[ __ ] is so high that most things
don't get to me you you deserve a like a
[ __ ] medal I know something I do you
do hey a big one the [ __ ] wedding
cake mix mix with the awesome everything
you don't think that you could live with
him today
dude we would [ __ ] get into it if we
were all i mean we're playing
battlefront and we just being in the
same space we're not we need to be
separate you play games we are video so
that's the one thing we've always done
together we like we play video games but
also he's really neat and tidy stevis
Bobby is a complete opposite Steve likes
things where they are supposed to be
gonna heal early doesn't he'll just
throw it like no just disregard like
yeah every the world is his trash can
sometimes I feel like he'll like do
something I have to clean up right away
and then the Del Taco thing that I'm
like put it in yours following after
yeah you have to pick up after you do
literally literally have to pick up how
amazing what did the house look when you
arrived and walk through these doors
it was very pristine and how does it
look now after 15 minutes of Bobby you
don't even know what he did to our place
in Gilbert the trash compactor is
literally it was bad
I forgive maids at hotels yeah like I'll
leave them DVD players Oh like good
gifts no but because but they deserve it
yes yeah because I it's like you know an
aerial view of Vienna when we stay in a
hotel together the night before I always
clean up because I feel that bad for
housekeeping and I'm still on something
good you know what he's bad at all so
he's better keep man like his cars over
the years he doesn't give a [ __ ] and I
think might as well just be a [ __ ]
dump truck or something cuz there is one
truck in Poway his uh when he was in
between going from
La Jolla to LA he had a white Toyota
truck mm-hmm he had starbucks
Frappuccino bottles yeah like just
filled to the top guess what was inside
I like it
my own pee I like the color it's warm
Jenna and I we clean out his car we
found there smells a big block of what
look like it was like a big block they
look like a truffle yeah but a giant
truffle cuz it was the mold had right
it's all right 2018 you guys are you on
my side I do PN things can I make you my
to make amends to you look at my eyes
then I'm good
I love you man I really do and I'm sorry
for you know the threats and coming at
you that way because I was just upset at
that moment and it was you know and I
want to apologize to everyone in the
room because I know it was uncomfortable
you don't have to but uh I realize
uncomfortable and he got really
uncomfortable I loved it um and I
apologize if I made you know if I
offended anyone I didn't mean what I
said I was just kind of you know what he
said to me - you're fat do you hear that
you're gonna see that you're gonna die I
was just trying to say the most perfect
and then you know what I did I got you
to be in a circle I want to die
yes I want to die I want to die
yeah yeah yeah which made you even open
book man I don't give a [ __ ] what I said
yeah yeah we were out there Bryce
Gilbert and I were on the couch just
waiting for you guys to finish fighting
and we were trying to like have a normal
conversation but the random like you
would get louder and louder like well
yeah fat cause I was like so this year
I'm trying to be a vegetarian
I will kill you yeah and I'm eating
potatoes and so I finally told Bryce can
you close the door so they can fight on
their own yeah you wanted to hurt me so
bad but you're right there was only two
little bars left like you had me in the
red I know there's like think that it
would have been honestly out he was at a
point of no return that would have been
the oven you know that's why I walked
out I was like I'm gonna let this let
them have that I just followed her I'm
ashamed cuz I'm not blaming my father
yeah but that comes it's derivative from
my father it's like some Luke white
Skywalker you know and Darth Vader
I believe it and it's like I'm ashamed I
mean but I need to I'm you know I need
to contain it but maybe not I'm an adult
and I shouldn't be but but also you need
to respect his I mean that the thing is
acceptance I have to accept just the way
he is and if that's the way he is then
that's the way yes I can't no I mean
come on man that's the way you I'm just
saying that's the way I am no no don't
don't don't get it you know I want you
to I'm asking you a question
I'm you see what do you need that's the
way I am well with certain things I'm
perfect okay stop stop everyone stop
everyone be quiet I don't say nothing
but I'm gonna say this okay I am a
[ __ ] fun machine can I just say oh
you are I'm a [ __ ] fun about it as a
fun machine when they're right there's
little kinks and and things right there
we go back in the [ __ ] 20s when they
made fun machines when people decided to
do those things different it was
definitely this is the problem with
Bobbie after he apologizes I'm so sorry
I messed up two seconds later I'm
perfect yeah
I'm like living in like I know I like
don't know how you do it seriously I'm
looking at you and I'm how do people
live oh Jesus they couldn't they they
were like oh my god
like billion too many [ __ ] furniture
walking on the [ __ ] water and stuff
yeah I mean in the end people were like
jealous and stuff what am I gonna do I
am sort of a masochist though I do like
a little bit of chaos yeah you do
so I think that I'm an agent of [ __ ]
chaos I'm an agent of fun well you look
at me right now will you thrive in it I
thrive in and thrive in it that's a
thing a nice that even the messiness he
needs that to do what he does on stage
and yes to be a comedian and that's what
anyone that's right I've taken care of
somebody so that I thrive in taking care
of that case I'll command you I command
you no seriously he I just realized now
like I don't know how you're doing and
then you have five Gazoo in here now you
got animal much like a bird or a parrot
I've gotta get a parrot and there's so
many animals and doing with him dealing
with what perfection
[Music]